[Music]
how is fatherhood treating you
fatherhood's good I'm 20 months in right
now I have a baby boy named Declan and
he's at a pretty cool stage now he's
starting to like say things and starting
to to talk and his first words were were
mama which I wasn't offended by I
thought that was okay it really worked
out good because what he would cry in
the middle of the night he went from
just screaming where if it's just a
scream it's fair game either of you
whoever's up has to get get him you know
but once he's screaming her name then
it's not like you hurt him a little he
wants you to catch another 40 wins but
now he's uh he's finally started to say
Papa which is awesome it's nice to hear
that but I don't really know if he knows
what that means the other day he was
like going through our record collection
it would just started yelling Papa Papa
and pulled out this album I'm like what
is he why is he saying Papa what is on
this record and I looked at the record
and it was Lionel Richie's dancing on
the ceiling he thought that is not
Lionel Richie now okay the movie this is
the end a very funny movie and of course
you all get to play yourselves in this
movie which is really funny you're
playing Danny McBride a version of you
subversion a very demented terrible
version of myself yeah yeah it's you I
know you and and you shot part of this
in in New Orleans we shot the whole
thing into one so he'll be shot Los
Angeles for New Orleans it's pretty
amazing what was it like hanging out in
New Orleans cuz you and the rest of the
cast you guys like to have fun yeah it
was a good crowd I mean it's like you
know Jonah Hill James Franco Seth Rogen
and Craig Robinson were all down there
for three months in New Orleans it was
awesome I mean when you're rolling
around Bourbon Street with that many
guys
things can get pretty interesting
sometimes I would I found that my move
was always to kind of walk behind Craig
Robinson he's such a big tall dude that
it's if anyone recognized anyone it
would be him and you'd kind of give him
up and then everyone could kind of run
away
[Laughter]
so like would you ever have like a whole
day off where you guys could just walk
around New Orleans yeah it crazy yeah
Craig and I one day had the day off and
we kind of ended up having this like
Ferris Bueller's Day Off sort of thing
in New Orleans where you know we it was
the
the day off came out of nowhere and so
we were both excited and we went to this
the absent bar on Bourbon Street and had
some absinthe and then we stumbled over
to the casino we both want a bunch of
money and we're just on top of the world
and we came outside there was a parade
going on and then Craig had got some
phone call from one of the I guess
someone who was involved with the with
the New Orleans Hornets the basketball
team and and they had offered us to come
see their last game of the season
courtside so we were kind of buzzed Rick
this is great let's go let's go see a
basketball game so we go there see
you're you're buzzed on absinthe you've
been cruising around for a while and now
you're at a hornets game and we get
there and we realized I'll drunk we're
gonna wear like this is probably not a
good idea like we shouldn't be here
right now so they take us to this owners
box they have all this food laid out
it's like mac and cheese and buffalo
wings all this stuff nobody's in there
like god this is great we can like kind
of sober up here we'll eat all this food
so Craig and I pile this plate on we're
all just back there just kind of going
to town and then awesome it's halftime
and the whole entire place fills up with
all these people including samuel
l.jackson but i've never met before and
they're in no condition to meet samuel
l.jackson we're in no condition to be in
public at this point so Samuel Jackson
comes over and I'm telling him what a
big fan I am I have like you hot wing
sauce all over my face and he and he
told me he was a fan of me spam but he
kind of came at me a little hard he was
like I like he's bound you got any
brothers in that show and I instantly
was like seeing that his character from
pulp fiction and got all scared was like
yeah yeah Craig's the show crazy brother
at that point we have a clip here from
this is the end and just to recap it's
feels like it's the end of the world
you're all yourselves well-known of
comedy actors soft doctors in LA and
you're trying to figure out what to do
to survive this madness exactly and
we're in James Franco's mansion and he
had we've run out of water and he has a
lot of water in this outdoor shed and so
now we've just drawn straws to see who's
gonna go out into the apocalypse to get
the water in Craig Robinson drew the
short straw okay all right yeah let's
take a look this book from this is the
end my took my pool in anyway or if you
get me screaming anything you quote me
right back in alright we'll try man but
you're pretty heavy
what no I'm saying what I something
smart to make any guarantee he's
promised to pull me back in know we're
got me yeah yeah we're gonna do our best
oh come on we do a test run yeah you got
a screw
[Applause]